[Music]
in our buddy check report tonight
although deaths from breast cancer have
declined slightly it is still the second
most common cancer among women in this
country but it's the leading cause of
cancer death among Hispanic women
Dr arcelon Solomon is with Optum care
Breast Care the latest CDC numbers show
Hispanic women are diagnosed in slightly
higher numbers The Five-Year breast
cancer survival rate for Latino women
tends to be lowered and Caucasian women
you know by about four percent so we're
looking at 92 percent versus 88 percent
plus it's more likely to be discovered
at a later stage Hispanic women have
higher odds than non-hispanic white
women to be diagnosed with tumors that
are larger and hormone receptor negative
making it tougher to treat once your
tumor becomes larger or your lymph node
becomes positive then you're hot you're
more likely to have a later stage cancer
invasive breast cancer is the most
commonly diagnosed cancer and the
leading cause of cancer death among
Hispanic women so awareness is key Dr
Solomon says one way to overcome it is
to have conversations at home so I think
that's the first place that it can start
where we raise awareness within our own
families you know to get your mom or
your sister or your grandma to go get
their mammogram
and of course that's what we try to do
here every month every month we
encourage you to do your breast self
exam either in the shower or laying down
because nobody knows your body body
better than you so don't put off that
annual screening either because like all
cancers it is best to catch it early